CLASSIFIED.
>> FORMETRUMP'S
STANRD F HILLARY CLINTONCLNOT H
HIMSELF TO.
OUR PANEL IS HERWIEEI KNOWWE KT
I FOUND MULT
CLASSIFIED IN
DOCUNTCLASSIFIED
AT THE LEVEL.
RESSMAN AN
SHOULD CONGRESIGATE
P OVER>> ABSOLUTY.OU BE INVESTIG
MANY THINGS.
AVE TH6t
HEARINGS TAKG
REALLY LOOKING FORWARDO SEE
WHAT THEY CONTINN
RM INVOLVEMENTH
THE INSURRECTION.
THE FACT THAT HIS HOME WAS
I MEANOBVIOUSLY A
REASON FOR ITOIZEDHET
THERE WAS SOME INFORMATION HE
S WHY THEY WENT IN TNTD CLASSIF
BE INVESTIGATED INVES
YO.
, A'S GOING
THROH ON OF THNG IS GOING
E P ACCOUNTABLE ARD.
>>ICALLY YOU W A'T THINKO.
E AMERIC
TIRED OF TRUMP'SS AND WHAT
HE REPRENTWH
TRRSG TOVANIZE BEHIND
M.ME, WE ALREADYE RS OUT T
.T, LISTEN, HE'DANGEROUS.
AND THE MAPORTERE
DAEROUS ANMA I
REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE
HIM.
HIM T T HI
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> IEECRATS SHOULDN'HA ORTED SO
BEE GEUS WHO WAN
NST AN EMAIL THIS MORNG IN
MAIL.LI, EYNG FOR YOUIS ICA A -
ANLDTHEI.
IT'S
CRIME OR YOU'RE .E  THAT THE T'M
IT'S CONVINCINTHWERFUL.LY DISAG.
POINS THAT
AMAT DID
COD THAT NEEDSTO BE HELDCC
>>K IN T I
SOMELING DONE THAT SHOWED
HIM TICKUPS
AMONG REPUBLICANS BECAUSERVENESO
LET THEM -- WE WANT TOM T. LM  .
WE'RE ALTOP.CIRCUS
THIS IS ONLY END ONE.
D OR MERRICK
GARLHA
SO, THIS HAS -- TO ME -- SAYHE H
D?
>> WEL THI TSIFIED DOCUMENTS. T
Y, THESE DOCUMENTS
AND THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
OUIN ABSOLUTELY.ENW  POSSIBLTH
BACK AND IT'S OVER NOW.ERS IS IN
IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T THINHEHELE
BREAKS THERICRITE.ING SOMETHING
AN.
THY KNOWS HE'S A
CON MAN.
THEY KNOW HE CHEATTAXES.
W D MULTIPLE
AND THZAU KNOW
AT THE HNE OF THIS IS NERMOR
KEEPAL ABOHI
WEEK WHERE DEMOCRATS FLYNT F
DO WITH THISAID.HEORISTSD
TOTALLY SEDN'S WEEK.A LOT OFHI
REBL A NGLE REPUBLICAN VOTE THIE
S.R LOWERINGOW, DRUG
OWE TAN AWAY RIGHT HAD FOR 50 Y.
WE HAVE A LOT TO TALK ABOUT.
I JUST WANT TO STOP TALKINT DONT
>>G
>> HE WANT
E WANE.
NE STOPPED TALKING
OF MONTHS, AND T IS
ARND HIM AGAIN.
>> YOU CAN S T LIKWERE
STNG LIKE, OS EASE FROM THISRIS.
THERE WAS A NATIONALL
DIGITS. HIM WITHININGL
THEN YOU DID SEE A AP
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING T
LAST.  HAVOLSES
G DONARU
I HOPE A SET OINT WHAT PEOPLAR
NOT DO THIS AGAIN.
>>THE
ELEC, TO BEA LOT MORE NEW>> I
WINNING IN CESS OVER THE WEETHE
OF
>> LETTMEN
IT TSING OF THIN
DOK TO DVI .S BI PASSING
ERE'S SOH TO CEB LET'S TALK ABON
DE QUITE
GOOD STRETCHNDT SEEMS
THATREN'WANT HIMO RUAGN IN 2024.
T' THEY'RE
D HE RUN AI THINK IT'S -
>> DYOE JON?
>>ONR THAT
>> I DON'T BELIEVE HE'G AFTER
TO RUN AGAIN?YAN
WELL, I WANT US TO KEEP
G AS DEMOCRATSHT
ING A YEARTWNOT THINKING AEA
>> HOW ABOUT YOU WALK AND CHEW
GUM TIME AND TELL US
IF YOU
NOW.ERE'THE MOTANT ING WE SHOUL
WE HAVE TO KEEP THE HOUSE, WCH
I DO KEEP MULTIPLE SHE SEN KNOW
HAVE THE STRENGTH D ONCE WE DO O
R S A PARTAKHINGT ABOUT HO AGGRU
GETENPROF THE
ED STATES RIGHT NOW?>> YES.
IF THE PRESIDENTS LL SUP HIM.
BEK YOER NEED S. IGHTI FMYINIONO
>> IT'S 2022.
O  IT OUT
RIGHT NOW?
>> BECAUSE YOU DON'T H